[Music]
yeah
oh
[Music]
he
a
[Music]
w
he
[Music]
w
my mic is muted there we go
amazing still haven't figured this [__]
out seems to take a long time for oh now
people are in here okay
cool what's up
[Music]
gamers
we're playing stard do Valley
[Music]
yeah nice what's up
chippy sorry no Terraria
chippy I I was thinking like I really
want to play Terraria but I've already
played it a lot so I thought it'd be
good to do a new
[Music]
game we're doing that today yeah
me and Mars have been playing Sardi
Valley and it's really really fun um so
I thought I it's a perfect game to
stream
actually it's kind of like uh Animal
Crossing with a different pacing I would
say I have not died in hardcore yet no I
have not
holdo can I adjust this window oh I can
nice okay we'll start in just just a
minute
[Music]
guys what are we doing we're
coping
nothing all right I can't sign where
they start singing I just want
background
music all right here we
go the soundtrack of this game is really
good um so I want to have that
instead
yeah tell my homie RIS to light his
girlfriend
Peg uh was super review on you should
give thus books that our sister I read
I've read it it's fantastic
um I saw the creat of Jojo came out with
a new anime called the spoke Rohan or
something interesting I watched the
first episode it was really [__]
funny there's a scene where his fate he
has to to survive he has to throw a
popcorn a certain height and catch it in
his mouth and it's typical like Jojo
anime style where it's super dramatic of
him throwing in this [__]
popcorn I like it so far but I seen that
people's review aren't very favorable so
I don't
know uh yeah obviously the the music
video got removed by YouTube and I don't
know I don't if there's a place for me
to address it is not during a live
stream but I also really want to play
today so I'm just going to say I'm
really disappointed and I obviously
disagree but yeah I'm not I'm not going
to address it further than that today
sorry
guys this is the cope
stream um but yeah I I don't
know part of me didn't want to go live
cuz I know everyone's just going to
[__] ask about it and I get it but
yeah not here
sorry sorry
gamers
yeah without further Ado then let's uh
get into this
[__]
hey name Chad for our name
Chad favor thing Chad
[Music]
so me and Maria are playing
the river I
think
yeah at night the monsters comes out
that might be
[Music]
fun wilderness sounds cool
Rocky terrain and winding River make it
difficult to design your farm H don't
want
that you can't have sprinklers in Forest
sprinklers are the best I'm not playing
without
sprinklers Chad Ville you're
right favorite thing alpha males
[Music]
the dumbest looking
dog yeah we'll go with anime
[Music]
PewDiePie
sure yes I wear shorts cuz I'm a man
thank
you
beard or no beard no
[Music]
beard now the real question oh I can
skip the intro
nice
uh I'm kind of curious about
Wilderness good forging fishing ton of
open space
however Springers don't work in the
sandy soil
[Music]
nah is there a no leg option I would
definitely pick
[Music]
it that's so G
fuel don't skip the inro why I've seen
it it's super
slow
[Music]
let's see Wilderness I'm feeling
it let's
[Music]
go all right here we go [__] I got a
carpet I like it already oh I can move
it
what so I never played on PC before so I
don't know what the controls are they
literally say okay run shift wait you
can
run oh it runs automatically and you
walk by holding
[__] ah it's so
[Music]
messy
uh oh
God the day has
begun we just got to get going clean
this [__]
[Music]
[Applause]
up so for those you don't
know you basically just have a farm it's
very slow pace but each day has a set as
you can tell it's already almost seven
so 1 hour in the in the world has
passed which means we're running out of
time to plant our first
crops where is a good place to plant our
crops maybe over
here yeah let's go here
here and also you run out of energy as
well in the start it's really [__]
rough I would
[Music]
say scy how do you pronounce that scy
sky
sky sky the sky
the um okay that's
good
we're speedrunning this can you speedrun
this game I'm sure someone's done
it
sight
sauno it's sauno
now always has
been okay so we're just going to clear
up a little bit make it nice make it
tidy [__] I think I'll plant here right
this is nice nice open
space maybe I'll keep my chests
here I don't
know I don't
know what's the ultimate way of doing
it
huh I need to
know
okay I'll go for like a symmetric area
like here
here how many do I have
50 was that seven
eight
God wait can't I make
fertilizer or do I have to learn to make
that I have to learn to make it
okay so we can't do anything right we
can just plant
[Music]
perfect we water these [__] and we
watch them
grow all right this is like the most
important thing you have to do first say
I
imagine look my energy is already so low
[__] I need those sprinklers
man what's another good thing to do
first day
this my energy is low and it's already
a.m.
cultivate it we ni suggested to
introduce yourself around town oh okay
fine
fine guess we'll go to town and say hi
to
everyone why do I have ginger
skin why am I glowing
red all right what's up hey hey talk to
me talk to me well hello there I'm Gus
Chef owner of stardrop
saloon never trust a man with a mustache
how do I click on
this what am I getting wrong here
e right click okay nothing's posted
today so this is the
town very cute
you should we date Gus potential love
interest can you date
Gus what's up the little
child oh it's a full grown woman hello
I'm I'm Penny okay I don't care
[Music]
Penny I don't care
Leah check the trash is that worth
it I never do
that can I pick this up O
Okay
um
okay feels a bit weird to go through
people's trash but
sure this is the
library
G hello there welcome to Stu Valley Arch
AR face this is EMB but the pro
correct hey if you can find artifacts
and minerals okay sure so you donate
them here and you get different
[Music]
rewards and here is the miner which
sounds weird to say are you're not going
to talk to
me Clint that's his name
clinty guess he doesn't like
me all right who do else I have to talk
to 28 people
I'm not going to find 28 people first
day is that even
[Music]
possible you got to go behind to speak
to the minor that sounds weird okay all
right we got douchebag oh [__] your
inventory is so small in the beginning I
forgot ah the new farma we've all been
expecting what a dick I'm Elliot live in
the little cabin by the beach it's a
pleasure to me [__] off don't like you
Elliot not a
fan
[__] I'm going
[Music]
back anyone with long hair you can never
trust oh God they dve is not watching
right oh
hello don't care granny I got Farms to
make who are you green hair girl no
thank you you must be Chad I'm the new
farmer the new farmer I'm car Caroline
don't care
Caroline get a job
Caroline so I don't know if I can access
this yet this is the town hall
yeah that's where you upgrade and no
wait that's where you make all your
donations and [__]
it's
Jack Fe what's the female version of
Jack jackqueline
maybe I should make a
chest start
my how do I craft I don't sorry I don't
know the
controls there we go 50 wood we can chop
some more
be good to have one chest at
least
okay ah I did not think this threw [__]
sorry trash you're going in the
trash
okay can I place it here like that's
pretty
condensed all right we can plant four
more don't know where I found
these grow my
children you can have
kids I need more chest dude I need to
chop more wood
guess I'll chop over
here
[__] oh God look at my energy how much
would I have
[__] guess I can't hey does it matter if
I give the dog water or
not Mar I gets very upset if I don't
water for the dog and I always tell her
it doesn't matter but she insists that
it's very
important maybe we can find some oh we
got
grass we'll keep some of the grass I
know you're supposed to do
that CU it takes no energy to do this I
might as well do this I don't know yeah
I'm not I'm not me finding 28 people on
the that's boring [__] that hey we get
some more seats though that's
good that's probably the best thing you
can do the first day is just try and get
seeds you have to pet your you can pet
your dog I didn't even know
that hey more seeds give me your
seeds we're going to clean this place
hey what that's a frog I've never seen
that hey P huge fans since 2012 however
last months I have been rough mentally
your videos always been there for me and
I just want to say thank you for putting
a smile on my face when I'm done jet
Wellington thank you hang in there man
things will get better or just play
stard
Valley
best way to
C
[Music]
hey I need hay for later you're
correct [__] I wish I didn't use so much
energy could have planted three
more another
frog so night time will come now am I
going to get attacked or or something is
that a personal attack or
something what is
this oh okay you get that later
right let me explore cuz this map is
different isn't it or is it just my
area 7:30 you know what that's a good
time as I need to go to
bed right what else am I going to do new
day our first day in stardo Valley is
done Monumental
Point yo we made 60 Gold hell
[Music]
yeah
nice one day many more to come let's
check the TV sorry I'm not used to the
control
for tomorrow it's going to rain okay
nice
uh yeah that's me Spirits are
happy that means we can go to the mines
[Music]
right
advertisement Pier [__] off pier I know
there's
like okay now we can get our fishing rod
cool let's water our
plants first
e they look
disgusting why do they look like
that and then we'll go and get our
fishing run
nice
[Music]
amazing gosh I'm
starving what time is it I'm out of
water as
well it's 12
okay
I'll probably actually break for lunch
really
soon but then we'll be
back okay get my fishing
rod dig that squiggly stuff up oh my
gosh thank you I Mara told me like
yesterday rusty spur
okay
okay hey P just want a shout out shout
out to spot Mak everyone
a woodpecker come to me all right is it
worth grabbing
that [__]
it hey another
[Music]
one there was an ad for a bigger
backpack okay how much does the first
one cost
5,000 I want it
should I introduce myself what's up
where are you Shane what do you want to
go with [__] off what is your problem
Shane
[__] 2,000 gold okay that's easy should
definitely buy that as soon as
[Music]
possible what an [__]
I'll make him my [__] I'm going to
romance Shane all right it opens in 10
minutes come
on come on
[Music]
clink
clink all right let's talk to him from
behind hey clink what's up um hi I'm
Clint
okay uh no why am I talking to him I
need to go to the
library AER Domin over Shane I will
conquer Shane's heart he acts tough I
can skip this right
[Music]
yeah okay what's the ultimate color
coordination here cuz once you put him
down you can never change it I think
I'll keep gray ones over here
done it doesn't seem like it had
anything to donate better okay can
understand you g
[Music]
you can change it oh my
God where are you Penny go away T Penny
I love Shane and Shane
only let's get a fishing rod down
here Shane is the sweetest boy well he's
an
[__] Oho there son there's a new
newcomer in town good to finally meet
you get just give me the rod Give Me
Your Rod man ah I'm still trying to
unwind from a month out on the salty
Seas it was a big Hall sold a lot of
good fish finally saved enough to buy a
new Rod so you can have my old one yeah
I want you to have my old fishing rod
it's important to me that the old they
are of all old fishing stat lab all
right
[Music]
hey bamboo
pole oh look how sad he
is there's good water in here in the
valley all kinds of fish
okay oh yeah my Shop's back open now so
come if you need supplies also buy
anything you catch if it smells it
sells that's what my papy used to say
anyway
okay so you unlock their backstory
through
Hearts okay I never really interacted
much with the other
villagers uh I can only really catch one
fish
here I really like the fishing mechanic
of this game why does it look like I
have
earrings oh got a little ahead of myself
yeah got a
fish just interact with Shane that's all
you got to do all right I'll [__] with
[Applause]
Shane I tried to fish a girl sorry
that's Soo okay let's go I'm
leaving blue hair [__]
don't talk to
[Music]
me oh you aren't exactly how I imagined
but that's okay what does that mean
that's so rude I'm so nice to
[Music]
everyone oh cool I did a quest I didn't
realize we need 2,000 as
PP sell this [__] sell that [__] we keep
fishing what's the so I know darker
water is good right is this a good spot
if I hit a Max no oh my fishing rod is
so
small hey Jojo
Cola so there's this internal um dilemma
in the game where you can either go to
the local shop
Pier to support local business or you
can go to the big Supermarket that
undercuts the prices of the local
businesses and run them out and then
hire the prices once they have Monopoly
of the
[Music]
area
uh but the thing is isn't open on
Wednesdays which is
tomorrow and it's always so annoying cuz
you always forget it you go to pier and
you're like what the
[__] [__] I already need Sala oh wait
let me put some in my
[Music]
chest uh but I got to say you know if
you're not open on Wednesdays that's
that's not really my
problem
and honestly Pierre is kind
of kind of self-entitled he he comes to
my house he sends me
advertisement Jo jakola doesn't do that
they leave me
alone I support businesses that leave me
the [__]
alone
[__] God it's so difficult to fish when
you have a [__]
Rod come on little fishy I'm getting
you
gosh oh my gosh give
up gotcha [__] what is this a
chub I always enjoy a good
chub what do I do with the trash I know
I can melt it later maybe I'll save it I
don't
know
I'm not going to catch fish here oh I'm
sorry what am I doing
then fishing a piec looks easier
honestly it's easier on Console because
your uh thing vibrates when you your
controller vibrates when you catch a
fish but it is easier to click I will
say
[Music]
that come on fishy I need money
hey we got that chub get that
chub yeah I'm keeping an eye on the
Salina don't worry
Gamers it's a very pleasant game it's
very relaxing
Until you realize how quick the days go
by hey more trash nice Max let's
go go see Shane I where where's Shane's
whereabouts
oh almost perfect oh what is that green
boy save up the rare fishes what
for oh yeah to donate later yes yes yes
yes is that joart my
man
yeah give me that
Cola [__] maybe I shouldn't fish now
actually my inventory is full again let
me put stuff I don't need in
here so is this
rare oh I need money more than anything
I just want more
inventory
save one of everything yeah I guess that
makes
sense oh my God we got a soggy
newspaper should I save is that rare
should I save this oh that's rare too
man I'm so
lucky yeah you can play this with others
yeah me and Mar play it it's really
fun it's a bit weird cuz when it lags it
just freezes your
um your side of the game which is a bit
annoying but other than
that it's pretty damn good
there's got to be a better fishing spot
[Music]
here oh there we
go
yes
yes o I got trolled
if you support Georg Mar you will not
unlock commuity Center it will become a
storage room of some sort are you
serious that sounds like a
[Music]
lie
it's true really so there's actual
consequences of going to Jojo Mart
[__] but don't you unlock the community
center right
away oh perfect fish let's
go
[Music]
Bullhead
it's better to fish in the mountain okay
yeah the day is almost over I I'll find
a better spot next time
tomorrow it's getting dark
Gamers yeah I know you get different
fishes different
places
all I'm getting is Saga
newspapers should we drink a cola how do
I drink
it tastes so good I love joa Cola
they're the
best can I chop it down
without oh my
God JoJo Cola sucks
dude I don't want to get
exhausted maybe we should go to
sleep it's so expensive [__] no wait let
me sell my fish
first
wait what did I just
do I assume the trash isn't worth
anything
[Music]
hey level up let's go let's
go hey we made some decent money all
right JoJo Mar spawn of Satan you guys
really hate jojamart
huh hey I don't have to water my crops
today
sweet let's dump all this
[__] so I'll keep that let's go
fishing or maybe today's a good day for
the
mindset let's check the
spirits I see a glimmer Within my crying
orb A Shard of knowledge of the future
they're
neutral I need to unlock the mine first
oh how do I how does one unlock a
mine check that de there
for for luck I should checked the that
there man
thanks for the tip I'll check
the what's going on
here open up
[__]
thought I could cut through here go in
the
tent
na I'm wasting time now for homeless
people come on all right talk to me a
stranger
hello don't mind me I just live out here
alone you're the only one I love
can I steal his stuff dude you're you're
richer than I
am let's find
Shane it's telling me has a nice
ass could chop some trees is it illegal
to chop trees here Mara does not like me
chopping trees in places where they
don't where it look
good but this is my my playr
okay my
rules if I want to go to joju Mart I
can let's go fish at the
Docks and maybe we can find
Shane
[Music]
come
on
yeah
sardine
penny is the best girl I doubt
it Shane is the best girl get out of
here perfect
no
ruined
[Music]
how chains sock shelf in JoJo Mar what a
loser wonder if I want to date a guy
like
that hey perfect let's
go
yeah ooh spoopy
sound
give me that perfect [__] yeah that was
a tricky
one [__] sardines they now
hariring oh different fish different
weather
okay and also time of day
right oh [__] ruined
it fish just gave
[Music]
up where the [__] is
Abigail uh would I alternate career if
YouTube didn't take up yeah probably do
it as a
hobby for
sure
nope no I ruined
it just want that 2K
man Abigail has purple
hair I'm [__] WI a twitch thoughts in
this game not happening
[Music]
no I can eat this seaweed
right [__] I'm so not used to the
controls okay I can sell my fish to you
right
bamboo pole what do I
have oh God I need so much more money
God damn
[Music]
it Abigail can play a tree flute ah [__]
that's actually awesome all right
Abigail also
potential can you two
time Shane got
chicken a Shane wins again where the
hell is
that some emo guy by the
docks hey man you
okay I'm not fishing you out if you do
anything he's
okay just get a haircut man it's going
to be
okay he's not okay a bro you want some
fish I got plenty of fish to sh oh
treasure treasure treasure what what doe
dilemma [__] dilemma
uh got gotcha
[__] oh you're so distracting on the
left can you go can you leave
please all right we got a treasure nice
uh you should try to do onee challenge
where you complete the community center
in one year it sounds hard but it really
isn't uh no I will not do that but thank
you hey look at that that's pretty
that's pretty rare right
yeah hey remind me before uh at
3:30 that I need to sell my
fish actually I should probably go now
one last
fish one last fish for the
road he's trying to make me flirt with
him he's trying to make me talk to
him oh I just noticed my uh bar for the
fish went up because I leveled up
fishing okay we got to be fast
here no more misclicking take my
fish
leave okay we got to make it to Clint
what the hell are the birds doing before
p.m. I missed a seashell but [__]
it I can sell one of these
right come on
Clint come on clinty
yes what up
Clint I can only sell one oh that means
tomorrow we'll definitely have it okay
it's closed today anyway so it doesn't
doesn't
matter Frozen geode no I can process my
GE don't close don't close don't
close can I process geodes oh I can
sweet
ooh gam
style nice thanks
Clint okay well keep the blue stuff I
want that blue
stuff
here nice
clean and I think I will head
back selling stuff at home will give you
more money what that makes no sense it
should give you more money money to sell
to the merchant H all right I didn't
know
that should I check out the saloon I
never check I never check out the
saloon yeah I doned everything uh to the
library that I could relax who are
you go
away Alex oh hey so you're the new guy H
cool yeah that's
me
salad whoa maky roll
oh spaghetti why is much I never told me
there's spaghetti in this
[Music]
game where's
Shane
[Music]
this is not fit at
all yo I never played
these whoa a game in a
game I don't have those my keyboard
doesn't have those buttons oh this is a
[Music]
problem skull-shaped Keyhole I get the
skull key later is that where you put it
I didn't know
that all right let's clear up our area a
little
bit give Pam a beer is Pam and Al
coholic you beer to Shane to fix his
alcoholism wait they are actually have
drinking problems in this
game oh spoopy sound
again
nice we can make another
chest I'll make this
green I'll make this oh gosh I had a lot
of
stuff this will be my foraging and this
will be my
stoning
[Music]
this I'll make you
black got so much trash dude
damn couple fishes for the
road there can only be one local
alcoholic
[__]
I want that perfect
fish
yeah
CH a don't spoil secret stuff guys come
on
I hear
something I'm getting
attacked can I kill it I only have an
axe I don't have my sword
yet [__] this I'm
out sleep
sleep hold
up dude just let me sell
bro yeah back
up
o nice we can craft seeds and we can
make a snack hell yeah I recommend use
oh there's mods you can use nice thank
you brear I'll check that out actually
I'll screenshot
that
okay hey we can make
baits but we can't go to the mines yet
when can you when do you get the
community center and when do we get the
mines cuz that's what I
[Music]
want
no I don't have enough yet all right
hey
oh I need a
scarecrow accidents
happen is that what attacked me
yesterday or was it a
bat oh my precious babies I'm so
sorry
uh wild horse radish daffodil leak and
dandelion I should have saved them
shouldn't I
[__] been been loving all the your
massive inspiration be since Amnesia
baby hell yeah cator hell
yeah I can't make a scarecrow yet I know
no breaks my
heart all right we're going to catch
some fish we're going to sell it to
schunter I don't know his name and I'll
get the
[Music]
backpack Shane likes joa Cola okay I'll
give him my joa Cola then ooh
shells oh give me
that so wi chest outside the house cuz I
don't want to go in and out every time I
want to craft something [__]
Noob all right here we
go I like how he fishes before he goes
to job his
work okay I got to harvest before I can
make a scarecrow that's fair
[Applause]
let's get some good fish here now I
already ruin it dang it oh chest
tempting
me nice that wasn't too
difficult weak fish you're
weak yeah what do we
get super rare Shane hates jojola why
are you lying don't troll me I didn't
know
that all right go to work that's right
go to work
[__] buy a belt while you're at it here
we go perfect perfect and a chest
perfect and a chest no
all right that should be enough right
hey we get some bait that we can't
use that's not what I meant to
do all right I know I get more money if
I sell it but I need money
okay wait how much can I buy the new Rod
yet
fiberglass it's
tempting I'll save up for that next
probably
let's hit
[Music]
Pierce good old G
fuel oh wait it's
here
nice we can even buy some
seeds what should I get let's get one of
[Music]
each maybe two of
each [__] I forgot I'm
[Music]
poor
have I met everyone yet I only made 17
people prioritize cauliflower [__] well
I did all that wrong
then and 12 3 5
six
okay this makes sense yeah let's go with
[Music]
this
perfect okay what's another good thing
to do now that I have the backpack I
have all the
[Music]
[__]
nice I don't know what I'm doing how do
I get the community center [__] [__]
[__] [__]
[__] maybe I need to harvest
[Music]
first foraging okay let's go with that
why you look so sad little one oh I I
keep thinking you're a child go away
away from me
[Music]
Penny the cows looks so strange dude
where the hell are you Leah I met you
there's actually a lot of wild food in
there if you know where to look show me
show
me oh yeah there's a wizard I can talk
to
right
let's go meet the
wizard don't follow me don't follow
me oh nice so I'll save these cuz I can
craft stuff right and I think donate as
well where's the wizard he's up isn't he
I didn't bring my
sights there we
go is he
home he ain't even home
dude what a
[Music]
bit he locked the door he saw me coming
up it's like who the [__] is this
Swedish boy with an
axe
I love this
track
uh oh here we go
nice chop one more tree just one more
tree we have more inventory now makes it
so much
easier nice
oh God our area is a mess
ah oh
[__] oh God can I even make it back this
way maybe I should chop the trees here
first okay uh um I can make another
chest don't really have to but I do
[Music]
it we'll keep like I'll change it
eventually but no wait this makes no
sense I have a green chest for
foraging I know I don't know what to do
whatever random [__] is here okay
go to salon on Friday
okay someone told me to cross the bridge
which uh Bridge are you talking
about I saw something moving that tree
does that mean
anything
nope meant nothing
okay if I zoom in the
options what you mean
here there's a crack there let's talk to
the crack
guy do you want something from me no oh
lenis he's lenis can you romance Lis
hell
yeah there's a military base oh how you
doing man you look
down local scientist and father who
introduces himself as a father
cringe no one
cares
see I saw that move as well am I
crazy yeah I am
okay guess it's the
[Music]
wind my
boy what do you want leave me
alone yeah bro why are you giving
me [__] you you know one day one day
you'll love
me one day you'll love me you can't run
away from me one day you'll love you
can't run away from
me you'll love me one
day one day I'll make you my
bed hello Chad oh I blocked I locked him
in
[Music]
[__] [__] dude
let's get
these H
nice I don't know what to do guess we
can don't have much energy left day is
almost
over why why does Shane do me dirty like
that what does Shane actually like I'll
googly cuz now I can't know I can't
trust you guys
[Music]
Perfect
Pizza I ain't giv Shane Pizza who likes
who likes pizza and not then not soda
that makes no
sense yeah I like pizza bad soda nah
that's like not like in milk if you like
pancakes
bruh oh
beer not I'm not giving him
beer he's got a problem he needs to deal
with it or maybe we should boo him up
maybe then he'll love
him all right time to hit the
hay I want that fishing
rod 700 p.m. that's when I sleep
oh God we're so poor we're poorer than
[Music]
Penny this cannot I will not oh oh what
get what what who are you get
out see this dog
here give
it
I was going to take him behind the barn
and but uh you can have him okay yeah
I'll take
him yeah give me the dog
[Music]
absolutely
yeah let's
[Music]
go reincarnate
did got some new items in stock Deluxe
fishing
pole you can use the bait to fish faster
okay it's a Harvest
Time
nice so today I'll buy some new seeds if
I can afford
it thought I was done with
this a
JoJo someone told me to hold a scythe in
my hand so I don't M misclick
okay and then going go to Saloon at
night
right sounds like a
plane oh what is this uh Demetrius wants
some
bream should I accept
it oh my God just open
[Music]
dude I should check traveling Merchant
today I have no money I have need
money I'm so poor
[Applause]
oh [__] it
up [__] it up
again come on dude got to do better than
that yeah so I think there's been an
update on the game recently for the
switch at least such a perfect switch
game it's nice on PC though I will say I
like
it
God sometimes when I fish I forget to
Blink in my I skate like got to get that
fish
M ah come
on
yeah I'll save fish but I I haven't
gotten any good ones so far and I I need
money more than
anything watch a God damn it they're
almost too easy and I [__] it
up oh yeah good call on saving the gold
star pars net I remember
[Applause]
that
oh
ah don't forget to
[Music]
Blink
ooh
achievement
okay
flundra
got
since it's coping stream your uh stream
vide help me cope especially during
tough times dad has been suffering
stomach oh I'm sorry to hear that
man um I just
realized
no
um suck seeing him suffer yeah that's
awful can't do anything C and we're
cherishing our time with
him you'll get through it
but that's [__] rough
man you don't even have a flounder
[Applause]
cringe and
Chi
and F
go all the SM stick then fine
FL perfect perfect
boom Another and Sh
[Applause]
huh okay I'm actually going to sell the
fish here because I want to buy
seeds I'll keep the flounder cuz I don't
know I don't see those very of often at
least what is he
[Music]
doing
all right I can also sell
these give me that money okay what
should I buy
then cauliflower right 12 days to
[Music]
produce what
else
maybe some
[Music]
potatoes and uh that's it I don't want
to grow too
many [__]
beans potatoes have best profit that's
all got to say I'm not caught in Corners
here can I
make uh no I
[Music]
can't guess this is my fishing thing
now
[Music]
okay 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 7 eight
okay I want the
sprinklers takes so much energy to do
this especially if you click
[Music]
wrong
ah those tiny little green
knobs okay definitely saving up for
fishing rod
[Music]
next
have I checked out
[Music]
here what is all
this this is where de Dimitri Deiter hi
want to say thank you for everything you
do have been watching you since Skyrim
[__] that's long ago love for core music
and more
nice I upgrade my house here oh
okay
telephone kind of future are we living
in
[Music]
here hey give me
that yeah 69ine right it out the video
can't [__] believe
it he did it
again he can't keep getting away with
it this looks cozy I can't oh I
can't what are they doing just sitting
around get a
job
you can go to the m now
really didn't say anything about
it I don't know if I believe
that let's talk to these
fools [__] off
Vincent I don't know
you I don't know you
okay but you will
you
will ah my
favorite life's just better with JoJo
you look like you're having a good
[Music]
time um let me check the mines then I
don't really have time to do the mines
today oh emo
guy
cool cool
yeah so here's the mines I really like
the mines in the game such a cool whole
other aspect to
it yeah it's open you guess were
right uh we got a sword that's all you
got to
know
maybe we'll do one
floor hey look at
that hey
copper hold up this makes no
sense
die
our first enemies can we kill
[Music]
them I hate the Slime so
much yeah eat [__]
slime
ooh two geod
nice I already found GEOS why is it
telling me
now hey three let's go for
four
nope okay it's 5 is the time to go to
the
salon if I go to level five I I don't
have to redo these
floors maybe I should go for five once
I'm I'm already
here it's got to find the
exit I didn't pick that stone
[Music]
up come
on where is
he
come
on oh gosh yes nice and a GE sweet cool
so let's go back up so now next time we
go we can go to floor five let's hit the
salon what a tough day huh ly's going
back to his tent building some computers
I'm
sure
yeah the M are really fun I like
it here we go why haven't I not unlocked
this yet maybe
tomorrow all right everyone's supposed
to be here right hey you were right I
spoken to you hey it's Mr Chad [__] off
Pierre I not getting your seeds oh
they're married he's busy all right my
man my man don't you have work to do
that's my line that's my lung chain here
what does he want pizza yeah I'll give
him a I'll give him a
pizza spaghetti Pizza 600 600 6 600 for
Shane I don't think so I've spoken to
all
this i' about spoken to all these
fools
oh Super Saiyan guy
G there she you guys like
Abigail
what oh is it lunch okay nice I'm going
to take a break and I'll be be back in
like 10
minutes um how do I pause the
game okay I think I spoke to
everyone reach level 40 reach level one
to craft a scarecrow can I craft a
scarecrow oh we got so much to do Gamers
no I don't
okay let's just hit the
hay m smells
[Music]
good
nice I knew it was good call the stream
today feel good
man all right we're going to play more
I'll be
back I'll save these
yeah a little doggy little
Sensa okay so if I stop here it should
be okay all right be right back
Gamers
uh
thank you for waiting guys yeah hey we
can make scarecrow and
fertilizer and Crab Pot
let's
go
yeah that's what I'm talking
about thanks for waiting appreciate
it um o tough dilemma I want to go to
the mines
now let's check our
[Music]
Fortune uh-huh neutral I'll take
it hey
did we get the thing now good morning I
noticed you've been breaking some rocks
and finding or that's good yeah thanks
leave my property if you want to get the
most out of the you find you need a
furnace okay he has the blue plant R
laying around
[Music]
thanks all right we got a lot of stuff
to do now okay I know I know about
furnaces yep yep
yep
start off the day watering away Lune was
great I am absolutely stuffed I had
[Music]
carbonara and a protein shake my belly
big so large got a
[Music]
sixpack
all right let's not forget
Sven there you
go
um okay so we can craft a furnace 25
stone and a lot more copper so we won't
do that but we can craft a scare craft a
scarecrow I believe
5120 uh
uh-huh yeah we can do it
nice
[Music]
perfect I usually keep one chest where I
keep all my monster loot in I guess we
will split them
now which one did I say stone is a stone
yeah oops
[Music]
me sell hats okay poke come to old old
old house Pokey bring
coinies hat Mouse well I want a hat I
got
more uh if you can s 10 slimes you'll
earn your place in my adventurers Guild
Marlin give me some love from Texas at
7:00 a.m. was your best for I'm excited
for the future PS you have a natural
time for music we sure I love you P oh
thank you that's so
[Music]
nice th000 gold for a hat yeah it's not
it's not on top of my list but I I will
not play this game Without Hats let me
just say
that
this Clint is not even open yet that
[__] Clint the simp
[Music]
man I missed another male
seriously ain't got
time damn it looks weird when I can't
see the fishing run it look like a
peeee oh chest
chest
yes
what do we get ooh
sword
[Music]
okay look at my pee PE look at the size
of my
dick yeah I don't know why I'm wearing
earrings I'm so confused by it but hey
that's
okay all right should be open
now we'll first go to Clint the
S and we'll open our
GEOS
nice ooh that's really nice I'll take
that what the hell is that
slate slay
Queen now we donate
[Music]
what's up
gun all right blue
[__] Crystal [__] all the
crystals uh or should I call her
coordinate oh the troubles are life I
don't [__]
it pink [__] goes
here that's kind of GR
oh I had the sword as well
[__]
weapons this this makes sense trust me
guys I know game all right give me ooh
that's actually totally worth it
nice let's hit the mines
Gamers it's
[Music]
time
can I walk this
way there got to be a bridge
right yeah
nice oh fishing
spot I didn't get
it I'm too
close no I
[Music]
missed God damn
it wasted all that
energy there the emo he put me up to
this [__] God damn
it what up lennus how's your computer
business
okay
hey floor five let's go kill the slimes
10 slimes they said
right all right that's two help me
count
nice
what
so I need a lot of stones actually for
the furnace
right oh that's a lot of slimes boy so
that was
four 5
six I found them easiest to just lock up
in a corner
seven I actually I actually need these
Stones number
eight what a sound dude
Jesus nice one more let's go see if
there's any copper on this
level hey number
10 that was easier than I
thought
nice no that's not
that that's not it
either
okay they open at two I
think
oh my
God no
copper what the [__] is
this
Hey where's exit did I already unlock in
it no I didn't
okay oh that was
quick I almost said Quack Like fast and
quick
that was quack you know
[Music]
what I assume the sword doesn't take
energy I just want to kill them for
killing sake at this
point I'm Stone
hard all right I'll just try and get to
10 really quick and then we'll
go we're at eight
Gamers
[Music]
oh why do you hurt me I just want you to
die is it worth doing this 1 two
three
it's a lot of stone
though you hit it eight times and you
get 10 Stone I think that's worth
[Music]
it all right floor nine one more let's
go
nice what is this
amethyst
[Music]
Abigail Oh I thought he missed
me the mes are very easy in the
beginning like even if I get hit doesn't
really
matter right
right right
[Music]
[__]
I could make uh food right no not
yet let's get the
copper look at those
crits nice oh there's
exit I'm out I'm out Gamers what do we
get
[Music]
boots
oh sorry but the menu makes no sense
where's my inventory there
okay you mean the inventory thing okay
even though I'm done I always feel like
I want to go one more oh God I'm
trapped never mind then let's go to the
adventure
uh the boots are just C I don't need it
I don't have legs I wear them on my
pee uh they want me to kill a th000
slimes [__] you better get something
good out of all
that increases knockback by 10% that's
so
[Music]
bad
no come back we got somebody show me kid
have I not joined the adventurer Guild I
killed 10 slime
how do I
[Music]
join they sleep together on a bunk bed
that's
[Music]
cute I've already joined
snore oh
[Music]
okay
okay let's go back plant the nine
califlower that we got oh she plays the
flute that's so cute maybe i s for
abigil I can't talk to her cuz she's
playing stop
playing
um oh yeah I should eat the Alia you're
right thank
you I'll give me some energy and then I
have enough to plant I haven't unlocked
this yet and I don't know
why it doesn't even matter how hard I
try keep that in mind but design of my
lime and my shine oh cuz I rhyme with
my swine and
my sometimes I go drink wine
and
[__] what up S
oh oh that's cute he just like Dash
towards me to then go to
sleep
see we're very low in energy I want to
be careful here one two three one
more if it comes to it I'll drink a fish
yes I said drink a fish I am that big
brain where's my watering
can there you
are oh no don't waste was
it ah
no what do I
do I can do it I can do it
believe yes all right we're good go to
bed farmer Chad apologize for joking
about your grandpa old Cottage when we
first met it's a really nice house [__]
all right Robin I don't like you how
dare you insult my granddad's
house he teleported nice do I have two
dogs Cherry Bomb all
right I'm poor poor as
[Music]
penny queen of
sauce stir fry
okay they're annoyed today all right
guess we're not going to the
[Music]
mines let's get the
juice and Juice up water with G
[Music]
fuel God they grow so slow I want the
sprinklers so bad
we'll make a
[Music]
furnace a look at Sven so cute sleeping
in the sun don't get dehydrated my
brother so how do I pet him I just
watered him
him
um okay
furnace that was
[Music]
easy we can only I only have three
copper or no way yeah there we
go that's not where I
clicked
oh
what else can we craft
fertilizer nice let's use
that is it too late to add
[Music]
fertilizer
no a
[Music]
ah
shame don't I have all of
them I could craft a recipe but I don't
think it's worth
it
[Music]
if I hold shift it makes five at a time
okay nice that's a good
[Music]
tip
nice he ran away I petted him and he
ran
it's too [__]
hot
okay I could make some more
seeds is that worth
it my instinct says
yes or wait I can't I need
leak
uh I don't know
then we still very poor out
[Music]
here oh speak of the devil
I go to the community center why cuz
it's been a
week oh cool we got the community center
nice let's see if we can donate right
away so this is uh how I guess you
unlock stuff you get different rewards
by donating and the housing
prosos it's pretty cool
yeah so let's check here
first oh oh I need to go to the wizard
first he deciphers it that's how that
works I guess he'll send me a letter now
build a coupe
how much that how much does that
[Music]
cost build a silo
first I ain't building [__] I got 400
bucks dude 400
bonis wait who's that girl I haven't
seen her
before or have
I
hey I'm taking the day up no one asked
no one
asked no I met her damn
it I could sell my kittens you are right
that would not be a bad
[Music]
idea
I'm going all out
Gamers taking my enemies with
me can't stop me I don't
[Music]
care
will fertilize the
Earth they will grow
fast Sven don't run on the cops
please now the green will make us
[Music]
green
what should I do then
fish what does one do in day like
this
fish clean up this
area I never use fertilize I'm too lazy
it makes it grow so much faster though
at least a day quicker it's totally
worth
[Music]
it
oh my God what a mess it is
here hey we got coal
shell sell for a decent amount yeah I
was going to go to the beach anyway get
some fishing
done I ain't going mining today
mm- I only like to go to the mines if I
can commit my full day to
it where have I not met yet hey you want
this oh she loves
it okay
[Music]
I needed to donate to the museum really
but [__]
it 300 W to fix a bridge oh where does
the bridge go we got a
shell what are you doing here
[Applause]
Elliot I want that fishing
rod
[Music]
she loves amethysts okay that's what I
thought that's why I did that perfect
fish perfect fish perfect
[__] hey we can sell
that whoa whoa
she slowly creeps over no that's a
dude can't you
tell oh I messed that
up Ed is cool are you
serious who
wears oh God I got troll who wears that
h no he's an
[Applause]
author yeah I love fishing in this
game
no
[Applause]
Fabio perfect no are you
serious uh we're in our first week in
stard Valley we're just trying to make
some money right right now and unlock
the
fundamentals we got the mine we got
the town hall we just need to unlock the
wizard thing I don't know how another
one what the
[__] yeah fishing gets a lot easier
doesn't it it's hard in the start what
did I take his favorite fishing spot why
is it staring at me stop it you're
distracting
me a still got perfect [__] this is my
fishing
spot he's not giving up is
he ah ah get away from me get away this
is my
spot you cannot do
this he's touching
me this is not how two men fish no this
is not
Titanic get away from me where though
you
smell you're not distracting my perfect
fish
yes it's going to push me
in
[__] [__] get
away it made he made me ruin my throat I
can't believe
him surprisingly I got perfect every
time he's been near though so
maybe that wasn't perfect [__]
where does he stick that rod that's
all oh no you can't go fishing in the
ass please Perfect fish perfect fish
perfect fish
yes perfect flound there
nice oh I'm exhausted oh
gosh did we do a lot today
oh yeah I guess we have so many crops to
water now we take a lot
of take a lot of else tomorrow we'll hit
the mines want to get some more
[Music]
copper or maybe the crops will grow and
we can get our better fishing rod I
don't know we's see all right bye oh
that's a perfect fishing
no
whatever
[Applause]
I could could have eaten the kelp you're
right
[__] now I'm going to
bed can I see the wizard now I thought
he had to invite me with a letter first
that's what someone said and I don't
remember if I don't get a letter
tomorrow I'll check him
out
all right boom boom boom boom boom boom
boom boom
oh good night
Sven I can't pet him what are you
talking about whoa
Jesus money that was a good day
damn okay I expect a letter in the post
H what is this oh I can pet him cute uh
living off the land welcome to living
off the land we're back up again listen
up let's talk fences
okay
great spirits are happy
perfect and we got a letter from the
wizard
yeah
come come come my
child potatoes are growing
nice this is honestly kind of a pain to
go to the wizard through
this
maze
Quick Stop hey that's so cute slippy
livs all
[Music]
right
oh there it
is not
interested
so now we can hit the community
center
cool what happens if we go this
way
nothing
hey I made all this going on with
YouTube good on yous for playing whole
song game hell
yeah the
copium right there's a merchant there
sometimes you're right I forgot about
that
uh I'll bring these just in case to see
what I can donate
then again I don't want to fill up my
inventory I won't need a fishing rod
right
now all right let's hit the
mines reach level
wait
okay you can see items to donate to your
community Through the
menu
really so I don't have to actually go
there every time to
check let me just see if I did it
right so now I should be able to read
this okay cool we need this is summer
winter spring we're in spring right now
right yeah I used to have all of these
now I don't we got to make sure we get
that done at
least and then there is nothing here
yet not even fishing
yet okay
right I have to physically donate but I
can check that's actually really
helpful why is it so freak I'm so hot
dude nice I need
that
let's go to 10
baby a little mole
rat not
[Music]
interested oh
okay what the [__] is happening
I do kind of want
[Music]
that it's cool you can D
them nah
nah murdered oh it's not
de
they're so annoying thought the spirit
was in good
[Applause]
mood I think there's a mine cart at the
end of this
right nice and they have
coal that I want
[Music]
nice
copper
what another gift for Abigail I guess
[__] I should donate this
[Applause]
one get the [__] out of
[Music]
here white okay
Alay that's
pretty
uh show me your
moves [__] you got
moves guess we got to mine our way out
of this one huh there we go it wasn't
too bad 13 14
oh
[Applause]
crap what is this
topz he hit me a lot what the
[__] going to run out energy real
fast so hard in the
beginning
uh-oh missed me
[__]
where's C
[Music]
ex there we go thank
you nice 15 if we can make it to 20
that'd be great but I don't think so
shoes are they better one defense no
they're not
better I'm going head out soon I'm kind
of sleep enjoy the game p hope to see
you play more star hell yeah I will
thank you for man for
joining it's like I'm tickling it to
death
[Music]
dude miss me [__] miss me [__] okay
you got me there
fine Diamond this early [__] I didn't
know that all
right fully
stack help oh
[Music]
yeah 16 yeah we're definitely not making
it but we can get some [__] anyway a lot
of copper on this
floor oh my God I think I move up but I
don't
is it cuz I'm no it isn't
okay
weird use my psyche okay all
right give me your meat give me your
meat oh ah I hate
them what I totally hit
him another one oh my
[Applause]
gosh
[Music]
me shame we're not making it to 20
[__] or
maybe just
maybe let's get the
coal y PS watching since I was 16 hell
yeah 22 now
damn what's the main purpose of the game
to have fun like any game uh I just like
expand your farm get different items we
made it to 20 holy [__] I didn't think
we would I need to eat something can I
make bug meat yet no I can't all right
uh is it worth algae I should definitely
eat
[Music]
algae
yeah I was really lucky there wasn't I
[__] I'll take
[Music]
it this last bit of copper there we go
now let's head
back what do we get now a sword right
yeah give me that [__]
[Music]
boy inventory is full too it might be a
good time to hit the hit the hay but I
was like to go one down before I go
up nice
successful get on home
Gamers back to
Sven back to
Sven you can't see my health oh my bad
I'll move it in a
sec
that's why you guys kept telling me to
watch my H I'm like dude it's
fine who just walks alone in the rain
what a guy oh I have I met him yeah I
have am I breathing into the mic too
much sorry guys
upper path is shorter yeah that's what I
always expect but I always forget the
slime in my
house stop it all right what do I
sell uh donate
donate I can melt that
uh yeah I think that's
it can I plant this what is this rice
shoot in Spring it is
spring
[__] should have fertilized it but
whatever oh now we can make the steak
and a sturdy ring
[Music]
okay what's the Earth crystals
[Applause]
for dang it I have
to
okay wait hold up let me move
[Music]
me
quick
watering I want
sprinklers I want money I almost have
enough to buy the fishing
[Music]
run we can buy that now then these done
no I'm going to run
out
[Music]
yep
come
on and one for my
man uh I should be able to melt copper
right
yeah watch's my monster chest
[Music]
here what do I do with the sneakers I'll
just sell them or I'll keep them there
for now cuz I don't know what to do with
them
probably I'll destroy them away uh same
with that
[Music]
[__] maybe I should make another furnace
what do they
cost 20 copper 25
St I think it's worth
it
that's that's more like it all
right hold up I need
this so someone said I can see what I
need to donate in the menu h do I click
on the community center no that doesn't
work right click on it
no is it
here
[Music]
ladders I don't get it where hey is
going through a tough time with mental
health and living in toxic place not
first time haha but your videos always
help me hang in there
Sunny so if it says like something on it
that means I can donate it or how does
it
work in your inventory the tree
button what oh there there it is oh
excellent oh my gosh I wish I knew about
this earlier
uh okay we have that and we have that
and that we need that
leak my man how you doing what what do
you want go
away you want a
diamond you can't have the diamond to be
fair I'll give you a pizza man don't
worry I'm giving my [__] a Pizza he's
going to love me once I get him my
pizza got all the B man cuz my gave my
main bch of
pizza call her coordinated it will fade
to purple trust me trust me trust
me do I get
anything
melon nice totally worth it
Epic
[Music]
we'll go south we fish
Ao no diamonds aren't that rare don't
worry
Gamers oh finally found one uh where's
where is it boom yeah okay anchor what
never seen that
cool no I put my fishing rod in my
[__]
thing hey discount please please
discount where you
going bro open your [__] shop dudee
what are you
do uh my heart it burns 1,000
miles fine I forgot about the geode one
geode
maybe maybe there's a mineral that I can
sell and then we
can yeah let's go with that we got a
plan we got a plan don't worry trust the
plan trust the
plan trust the plan hey you want some
outgate it costs 25 though [__] I didn't
count for that [__] and it's copper
[__] copper dude you [__] you
Clint you
clicker I wasted
hours where are you
going I thought I clicked no what is
[Music]
happening nice
shoes feel like uh she's uh flirting
with me a little
bit girl don't compliment guys shoes
whoever made this game have never Spen
to them are those made out of
plastic the [__] is she on the
about I'm
bored I don't trust I don't trust that
[__] ain't nobody tell me about my
shoes for my 31 years of existence I
never had a woman compliment my
shoes and I wear killer shoes and that's
why I know cuz I'm still waiting for the
day to
happen sorry S I forgot about you got a
lot going
[Music]
on
curse me for trying to save inventory
[Music]
space what is this
nothing where is my
fertilizer
[Music]
okay
nice no out of season then what do I
have
[Music]
it no
way is there anything I can
craft Crab Pot I need iron I don't I'm
not even close to
[Music]
iron thank you
Jeremy
I need to do some foraging and find the
things to
donate but I also need
money look at that cow
[Music]
as I'll take
it
[Music]
another one it's not what I
need
are you lost little
one giggle I'm giggle at me
child South for leak is that a known
fact that you go south for
leaks someone just said leaks are more
commonly found around the mines
so who can I trust here [__] guys get
your [__]
together it's locked he all right there
a lot of Mysteries to this game spring
onion n what is
this onions onions onions and leaks are
not the same
Gamers they are two different
things oh my God you got you guys
embarrass yourself just like don't
comment unless you know what you're
talking about my
god oh it's a hat
grow
I already have a
hat no I'm
good most relaxing games to ever exist
the sound designed deserves chilling and
word hell yeah that's a really great
soundtrack froggy
I'm
Stucky
come
on Sven guide
me did I forget to water
this
impossible okay so someone said if I
hover over it and the tree thing is
pulsing then that means I can donate it
so that pulses this doesn't pulse so I'm
getting the [__] rid of this
[__] that doesn't
pulse that pulses that doesn't pulse
this pulse
pulse all I'm going north for leaks
then
is little Nightmare 2 any good I
um I don't know if I'm up for
it I like the first one it was really
good but then they made so many DLCs
that I felt like I couldn't keep up
anymore and I don't know what's going
on let's do a quick leak run
here lonus has some leaks I know
it where the [__] are you oh my God you
weirdo leak leak leak leak leak leak
leak leak L is the
leak
[Music]
don't I've been lyed to there's no leak
I should have really used my energy
maybe I'll chop some
wood
uh-oh they're
coming but I can kill them though
right [__]
whoa that's so cool with the
echo [__] the
Slime [__] the slime
let's chop down one more and then
sleep
I need to put some lights up but I can't
be
bothered
Burger changing the
game my windows boarded up oh my tulips
already Robin here know there's a lot of
stones SC on your farm if you have
Surplus you might consider having me
build a well for you Wells can place all
over rearm and serve as convenient
placees to refill your watering
can uh no no no way I'm getting a
sprinkler system some crops died
seriously
[Music]
shame
oh God did I right click instead of left
click are these
done oh requires
sign kale
[Music]
gang nope need
that
[Music]
that was a leak that wasn't
dead it just looks like that oh no
what
seriously
[__] I'm an
[Music]
idiot dumb I'm a dumb
dumb all right so
spring
need one
more one [__]
[Music]
more how do we get 2K so fast dude I
can't close don't [__] [__] you Pier
suck my
dick I'm going to Jojo Mart close some
Wednesdays huh what are you doing on
Wednesdays Pier what are you doing on
the
Wednesdays explain yourself why aren't
you hiring
[Music]
[Applause]
saf
Wednesdays are
cursed I don't like it let's catch two
more fish so we can buy some bait as
[Applause]
[Music]
well
you don't like fishing in this game it's
so fun I love
it fishing little water P outside the
spa you get some secret things there oh
[Applause]
okay good
tip
chest
what do we got hey I'll take
you fiberglass Rod all right I need to
sell first nice and then we get some
bait for the
rest sorry someone says there's a rock I
can fish next to where where is this
rock this
rock that would make sense oh it's
deeper ocean there I just
realized wait which one is the better
one wait how do I attach the
bait there we go right
[Music]
click should go quicker with the bait
now right come on it's so fast I can't
keep up give
me is the prophecy
true oh tricky fish Tricky Tricky Tricky
Tricky
[Music]
okay hey when I [__] up a perfect just
cuz he was at the
bottom I clearly have not learned these
controls
yet long boy hell
yeah
garbage so I right click and then left
right click again never
mind
simple
strawberries are good for
money okay I we'll save up for
strawberries
then perfect
[Music]
no sorry what I can put the
no oh my god dude D what I had no idea I
could do that
oh oh
thanks oh that makes so much more sense
I was like why would it have to tell me
I Ed my last bit of bait every time I oh
my I'm so dumb
[__]
flounder cuz I'm a floundering
fool
but I catch perfect fish so what you got
huh
yeah that is not where I want to toss
that oh my God stop it
[Music]
please
ah
no why does it do that why does it do
that I'm not moving my
[Music]
keyboard I think soon I I get fishing
that's I can choose a profession if I
want to be
like crabber or Fisher and I make more
money out of fish yeah this is
definitely way better good tip
[Music]
guys ooh Happy Birthday to Brian Mal I
don't know who that
is
but yeah happy birthday yeah yeah
[Music]
sure why is everyone spamming that
[__] finally what
what
POG I'm so
[Music]
confused
fresh oh what he
donated sorry Brian have a great
birthday
man all the
best is it worth getting a crab pot no
I'm poor don't even think about it
[Music]
[Applause]
Felix oh that was
close
thank you yes no what what do we get
what do we get hey and now I can bait
that right away
[Applause]
nice what are we saving up for next
maybe upgraded pickaxe could be good
we can do some damage in the
[Applause]
mines you didn't know about putting bait
on the right either okay glad I was near
only
[Music]
one get more crops [__] I don't know
it's so annoying to water them I don't
like
it hey you're trying to sneak away oh
treasure treasure and perfect or did I
[__] it up no
close coal I'll take it
cool well make sure you save up for St
all right fine I'll save up for
strawberry [__] what do you want from
me
oh is he going to get the treasure of
course he is he's the [__] King yeah
look at that
[__] slide right
back and Sh
we
yeah I don't even have to get by bait
anymore what the
[__] upgrading watering yeah that seems
good especially if I don't have sprink
cles yeah yeah maybe that's the best
thing to upgrade right
away but then I can't water my plants
while I upgrade
it do I have to wait for rainy days or
some
[Music]
[__]
[Applause]
uh-oh tricky one
huh I'm full again
[__] upgrade water and Canon winter well
then by winter I will have the sprinkle
system mark my [__]
words
oh Clint is closed Clint the
simp favorite YouTuber thank you imagine
the odds I don't I never imagined can't
literally can't have I met
you uh no one ask my main
[__] ah he's playing hard to get that's
so
cute he loves
me all right give me that leak give me
that leak what is she doing just sitting
what
an
[Music]
idiot what's
this where's my
leak where's my leak where's my leak I
was promised [__]
link donate my Anvil you mean my
anchor you're right I keep forgetting
about
it wait
wait wasn't there a thing where it
pulses over if I can donate I can't
donate any fish right now doesn't
matter
I missed the fish somehow have I not
watered
today
what am I
crazy how's my energy levels come on we
can do
it it's tough
work I know
Sven
[__] eat some delicious seaweed num num
num so
good I look like such a K-pop
person with
my hair my chin and my
earrings I don't like
it
oh my
gosh God I'm such a
s uh since I like bladey and drain do I
have any
suggestions
I don't know anything outside of that
[__]
hell oh we're getting
attacked ooh nice That's good I've been
waiting for
that that's for our sprinkling system
guys cuz they make smooth quartz really
easy damn we made some
money [__]
oh that's what's up that's what's up
that's what's up that's what's
[Music]
up he
yeah upgrade backpack again isn't that
like
10K I got other stuff I need to spend
money on right
now it meant the world to him oh great
I'm happy
[Music]
Brian oh my
God try behind the bus for leaks
okay
[Music]
we're going to donate
this wait how much is the iron bar I
don't have
[Music]
that Mom gave me
cookies I water
this if I find Robin's
axe does it always spawn at the same
spot because I found it last time when
it was just in the
[Music]
South I can't be bothered right now I'll
do it once I'm there did I forget the
rice shoot again poor rice man I'm so
[Music]
sorry I want leak I want leak yes thank
you Damian thank you thank you thank
you
[Music]
cool let's
go but
where to the town hall of
course we completed our very first
singing
okay on the 13th you can buy seeds thank
you I'll keep an eye out this is not
summer you idiot there we
go boom boom that's how we done what do
I get spring seeds what am I going to do
with spring seeds huh that's
ridiculous oh
cool do we get fishing as
well please please please please please
please
yes Bing a bonga bongo I'm so happy in
the Congo no no no no
no parsnip cauliflower
potato yes yes yes yes so I need to grow
some beans then and
parsnip Bean parsnip
callif oh God this is so much
stuff G overwhelmed oh that's why we're
saving the five star of the
parsnip parsnip being
calar car went and
beaned his in the
park
okay car Bean in the park car being in
the park car being in the park car Bean
in the park car
[Music]
Bean
carban in the park car Bean in the park
car Bean in the park car Bean in the
park car bean
[Music]
bean let's not forget
plint
[Music]
okay so how much does it cost to upgrade
2,000 oh I could definitely afford that
soon uh and five bars which I have okay
that's totally worth it but for
[Music]
now what the [__] is that
Celestine okay think we can sell this
to carbine in the park carbine in the
park carbine in the Park
[Music]
oh
uh that's kind of grayish isn't it
bluish any upgrades
no
[Music]
making good
progress
[Music]
mine is it worth planting these I got 30
of them [__] 30 yeah it's worth it
but I'll I won't plant them
now
[Music]
car right now I want
cauliflower and
bean I forgot fertilizer [__] [__] [__]
[__] sh
sh
[Music]
I can still add them
nice's let's keep it this
way
[Music]
simple what up S
my
[Music]
man I got a couple more than I want but
whatever it's a lot of watering not
going to
lie for good
[Music]
luck
should I just trash the tools like what
do I do with
[Music]
them maybe the watering can first is
better honestly yeah I think so cuz like
it's not worth upgrading later uh liing
of line what is this hes from
crows what weather
[Music]
report it's written in the stars Gamers
tomorrow we're getting the water
[Music]
can let's do some quick fishing
then oh someone said fish in the
mountains let's try that a little
bit
[Music]
oh my God now I'm finding leaks are you
serious oh I should get the water can
today if it's
tomorrow that's not going to
work where is this Mountain Pond you
speak of
huh where
I've been lied to yet again oh fish
[Music]
spot wow thank you
Game I don't have the money
today think I made a
money
the crops won't die if I don't water
them one day
right
[__] oh my God
F how much does Robin Pay
Me Maybe Robin will pay if I get her
axe no that's not going to be enough
[Music]
Felix feed the chickens oh my God turn
to sound like Maria I don't like it it's
not my job you bought the chickens
okay
[Music]
yeah I think she gets 250 for the
axe fish
[Music]
gang
perfect fish gang hell
[Music]
yeah
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa slow down there
[Music]
son oh my
God
there's automatic feeder later I want
that for my non-existing
animals
treasure got to have
it
[Music]
oh wow two amethysts
okay there's an automatic crop
Harvesters oh my God automatic farm
since s the valy confirmed
nice I need it
[Music]
now I want the whole game to play itself
for me
automatic
[Music]
Miner do they have
redstone
[Music]
so nice with the without the bait thing
that I've been [__] around
[Music]
with
perfect
[Music]
uh you can expand your house later I
know you can do that I just never done
it we're in the early
stages oh my energy is already
low
last fish of the day
Gamers what is
it oh my God all right so now if it
pulses the
tree I can donate the Sunfish
okay and the
bream that's so
useful
that helps so much
seriously oh we caught that before I
should have saved
[Music]
it so tomorrow's going to
rain I should have upgraded the can
today but [__] it I'll get it
tomorrow and then on the 13th we're
getting [__]
strawberries you don't even
know I've donated these right I don't
remember [__] it I don't
care good night Gamers a SP on my
bed here we go uh resources required to
craft crab pots reduced 25% more fish
seems like such a obvious
[Music]
choice damn we rich we're rich
Gamers tomorrow holding egg Festival you
should ride between 9 and 2 if you like
to attend the annual egg hunt Okay can't
literally can't
wait I didn't sell my chub for some
reason
cringe let me grab my
cookies are these done
no
I get a straw hat oh my God I need the
straw hat
absolutely oh clean doesn't open until 2
hours I'm way too
early guess we can
fish in the
rain like a
loser raining means better fish oh okay
we've been doing a lot of
fishing Dam it's even easier
now I level
up
nice come on give us some rare fish
knock on
wood [__] God damn it
oops there's does it matter how far you
toss the rod at
all that was my last piece of
bait this is a
disaster how much a strawberry cost per
piece
[__] that was
close oh like the answer from the
gods thank you stardy
gods
oh it's my my girl my girl sorry I got
to fish right now oh he freezes when I
fish what is he doing that looks
[Music]
weird is it taking the piss what is he
doing oh diamond for my
queen he likes it I went shopping last
night and picked up fresh parts and it
sale for you are extremely boring Shane
what the [__] I don't give a [__]
that may have been a waste to give Shane
a diamond but he's he's my he's my
number one I love
him give me the copae
yes yeah get working fast okay I ain't
got
time never seen Shane smile before we're
getting there he's softening up all you
got to do is everyone has a price you
know and Shane is no exception
[__] give me that
[__] this turned into another fishing
day I don't know no that's not where I
was
looking you can plant rides next to
water so you don't have to water them oh
nice that's a good tip
thanks tricky fish no he's staying there
[Music]
okay that was terrible but we got
him do you want to date Shane no I want
the have consensual intercourse
cus is that too much to
ask what's that sound what was that
[Music]
sound Shane likes beer hot peppers
pizza poppers and pizza and diamonds
okay he definitely likes diamonds
dang
it hey mother
[Music]
catch there are weird sounds when it
rains I don't know why yeah mysteries of
stardo I
guess oh another one
is the game too low or Too Loud by the
way I I have no
idea I need to buy some bait
actually oh wait I forgot to
check
pulse oh I'll sell the good ones right
no pulse no pulse no
pulse so i s live fish with pulse on
it
when it rains you can find catfish in
the
river where wait is there a river where
I was before
or fish in the
river okay I'm going
back I did get a treasure though
so there's always that and I got some
rice shoot which I will plant by the
water what's up emo
boy I don't Sebastian go home go
home is this the
river I'm fishing here now
catfish let's
go got
[Music]
it best River places in front of the
mines
okay whoa whoa whoa could this be it
it's a tricky
one oh wo wo wo hey hey uh uh what where
you
going give up give up give up give up
give up give up oh my gosh dude stop ah
it's
killing
no oh my God it's annoying as hell
please yes I got it I got the catfish I
did it I'm the king what do I what
happens
now
what happens what did I
do does it pulse it
pulses oh we got some is that what I
think it is no it just
disappeared don't sell it for the love
of God but how much money did do it sell
for cuz I need money
I want
money wait where am I
now is this a
river what is this I never been
here
[Music]
job this is a lake ah
cringe so I don ate the catfish then
right oh my God is that it looks like
another
catfish l g
cringe someone said under the
mines I've been lied
to I'll take that
[Music]
[__]
sake I'm just wasting time now I'm going
back to where I
was
sorry about my friends they've been
drinking a little and got overzealous
there's 50 charity to make up for the
spam thanks everyone oh that's Brian
okay
great no worries have a good
[Music]
one oh what a [__]
fish a CH Chad we got a Chad in Chad
bille from Chad nice I love
it oh my God the door
slam Chad two Chads three Chads three
Chads three Chads come
on three Chads I will make my
life chub plus Chad is
Chad come on a chub or a Chad
please
[Music]
no well I want
Chad oh [__] Valentine's Day all my
homies wants
Chad
[__] off
bash nice almost out of energy
sh
[Music]
oops
ooh
baby tomorrow we're getting
strawberries what's
happening that's my
inventory what's up emo boy been staring
at the sea again
whoa oh this could be a I [__] up no
this could be a
catfish [__] you're
mine I don't think it is we'll see
catfish catfish you see this [__]
Sebastian Sebastian you can't come here
I mean
[__]
Sebastian look at get
it oh my God he didn't even
care some
people all right let's donate one of
them uh oh Chad get the Chad just one
more in the river fish okay and what is
it tiger trout and Lake I don't think we
have anything
uh vibrate sardine that's ocean isn't
it vibrate oh that
[Music]
vibrates vibrate vibrate vibrate
vibrate I have Bullhead
where is it in my
inventory now wait what the [__] am I
missing
then tiger
trap sergeon
car I'm I'm missing all of it what are
you what are you
smoking you guys need to calm down you
don't know what you're
saying all right bye bye bye bye bye Mr
PewDiePie no need that
okay so these go by the river
huh oh
zombies my man I'm just trying
to plant
[__] all right [__] it I'm going to
bed I got to get a g- fuel I'll be right
back
guys
go
for
trim my
mustache thought it looked a bit pedo
is just a quick snack we can talk about
life or
whatever I really really really really
like this
game when M showed it to me I was like
this is so lame what all you do is water
plant and fish like what
the you
know but it's so
addicting
300 for a
catfish oh chat is pretty good too not
going to
lie
garbage Fridays and Sundays check for
the traveling cart they can sell coffee
beans which are worth a lot
oh
okay good tip thank
[Music]
you God damn it I can't water
them
[Music]
I'm sorry plant I can't do anything
about
[Music]
him might be a good day to hit the
MST
hold
[Music]
up or back
cammers oh the egg
Festival are you
serious no one has time for egg Festival
especially
[Music]
me all right tomorrow we do the
Min [__] egg Festival when is it
start 9
[Music]
right oh oh
gosh ooh close call
gamers I'm a masterb f Fisher
fisherman
nice if I don't dig up the worms it's
cuz I don't see them so shout in the
chat if you
[Music]
do
yeah I recommend checking this guy game
out yourself if you have a switch or PC
which obviously do doesn't take a lot to
run it's really fun
all right 30 more minutes and then I'm
getting my strawberry
seeds
[Music]
[__] egg Festival has commenced there
will be no wasted
time
[Music]
nice excuse me
[__] man I am so glad I have a day off
today to just relax man I had such a
busy week holy [__] all of them wiped
them out
o ow that hurt to look at 24 all right
that's that's
good I hope everyone's enjoying the food
I've been cooking for days to get
everything ready fried eggs boiled eggs
poached egg deviled egg scrambled egg
chocolate egg do name
[Music]
it is there any more food Clint shut up
no one really talks to me I just can't
come for the delivered egg lennice I'm
talking to you stop being such a
self-loathing mothing son of a
[__] our hens have been working
overtime to prepare for this Festival
they deserve the best tonight balls full
of sweet yellow
corn what was that chain is that a
smile you love me you will love me
[Music]
[__] you will love me one day I look at
Shane from the bushes look at his hair
look how he e
breathes look how he just stands and
stares so
lovely all right maybe this is a good
chance to talk to everyone I always look
forward to these gatherings it makes the
valley feel like a real Community don't
give a [__] Penny I don't give a [__]
don't care you're a child don't care
you're a
child Elliot is hiding something and I
don't believe [__] he's saying Leah
equally
I don't talk to blue-haired girls I
don't talk to jodies I don't talk to
Hobbits I don't talk to old people not
yet um I don't talk to whatever the hell
that is I definitely talk to Demetrius I
have absolutely no quarrel with him
whatsoever I don't like
Robin I don't like Caroline I don't like
Willie this guy's cool he's got an eye
patch he's cool this is corpse Aid even
with my bad leg I never miss a Town
Festival hell yeah face
[Music]
reveal
amazing I don't like old
people eggs why eggs this say has been a
tradition for as long as I can
remember Embrace tradition reject
whatever the meme
is modity we Tau we used to do a rotten
egg P major Lew put an end to that
pretty
quick searching for eggs is like going
on a treasure
[Music]
hunt [__] H all right let's see what
dumb [__] she's going to say this time
this Festival is all right but what I'm
really looking forward to is the flower
dance oh I did this with Maria that was
so cute we did on Valentine's Day I try
to eat at least three eggs every day
what the
[__] got to get that protein
[Music]
I definitely spoke to everyone now
right 100% all right uh let's start the
egg hunt all right I'm going to get all
the
eggs
egg get out of my way children get out
of my way child the eggs are mine I need
that hat the hat is mine
yes away from genten egg egg egg egg egg
egg egg egg egg if I was an egg where
would I be where would I be where would
I be there's an egg egg there's an egg
oh I almost missed it was in front of me
two eggs two eggs let's go let's go [__]
off child [__] off that's mine that's my
egg that's my egg dumb [__] my
egg my
egg there's an egg I see it I was hidden
oh look at these fools they're not
finding any eggs the eggs are everywhere
idiot mine
[Music]
[Laughter]
yes oh more eggs D we got this egg in
the bag get out of abig Abigail get the
[__] out of here you ain't get [__] did
I take all the eggs holy [__] that was
amazing I missed one there but
[Music]
whatever let's go egg egg egg
just declare me
winner there's no way I lost that Chad
here's your prize en
Joy Champion
Chad Chad the
champion
oh no I need that
uh
boom okay maybe tomorrow my watering
Canon is
finished I didn't even put on my hat I
got
sowh got so ahead of myself let's see
yeah water en can is ready okay nice oh
my God oh my
God so pretty Smitty now we have the
water can now we got the strawberries we
are good I want to do a mining day but I
never get the chance tomorrow tomorrow I
will
mine today we
plant tomorrow we reap what we
s all right what we got birthday I don't
care uh oh actually when's Chain's
birthday
20th 20s okay we cannot forget four ing
sure we got to give him a pizza pizza
and a beer for his
birthday nothing
else this getting moonshine here what
the
[Music]
[__] oh there's my
hat nice that's cute I like
that oh I keep forgetting setting is so
[__]
[Music]
slow I haven't talked to the doctor yet
you're right I thought I did during
something sorry yeah that was my what's
[Music]
up I'm missing one [__]
person maybe it is the doctor I'll check
it on the way
[Music]
back do we need
Sunfish ah
chest
I never miss a chest ever give
me come on what's all the
rice I'm another
whatsa it never ends where's my
phone I was literally sitting on
it I missed it thanks
[Music]
what
work playing games
[Music]
can't oh my God I keep getting troll
anyway it's
[Music]
open give
me
nice so how much it cost for the 2,000
for the copper
pickaxe
okay let's head on back
[Music]
games so is there a shortcut back that I
don't know
[Music]
about is it quicker to go this
way no it isn't I literally just walk
around what if I go like
this this is no way this is quicker
where am I even going what the [__] am I
doing ignore me forgot to donate this
tail
[Music]
[__] this game just sucks you in there's
always something you got to
do you can eventually teleport back oh
yeah I know about
that uh anyway we got to focus on
watering right now oh he brought it back
to me with some water in it how
nice so I can charge it oh
sick oh it's splash the [__] no I
Bard
no
ah
[Music]
spash it still takes a lot of
energy my
[Music]
God oh my God I'm so bad at watering
Felix what's your opin
yeah I I said I wasn't going to make a
statement about it during the live
stream just cuz I know I'll just say
something wrong and it will come out
weird and media will't go all crazy but
yeah I'm disappointed and I disagree
with it but that's all this is why we're
coping playing
game it really
sucks [__] all right should we plant the
strawberries
24 [__] I had so
many makes sense to do six of them on
each row
then I'm so annoyed by placing that
there
[Music]
trust trust me it will make
sense fertilize this
[__] we're going to make so much money
now going to be
rich oh they look
[Music]
nice Sweden's got the best
strawberries wait I counted this wrong
how math
difficult whatever it works
out
and ah for [__]
sake oh my God I cannot do
it
splash
splash oh of course cuz of the rice
that's how I counted
wrong
dumb
okay clean all our energy
gone what the
hell trash we need a trash thing what
was that again it was iron wasn't it
yeah we don't have that once we get an
iron bar I'll make it I still have a
rice [__]
[Music]
sake
play V you'd really like it yeah I'm
actually playing it with the some
friends offline it's really really
fun I just haven't had much time
for uh yeah just been a bus a week I
haven't had any
time to play games for
fun
no no worries thank you
coring uh I am really low on everything
I'll drink a Coke wait doesn't this give
Health more than anything no it
doesn't I mean a joa
cola might be a good time to clean up
but I have so little
energy I'll do some [__] fishing I
guess we'll get we'll get an early start
tomorrow what's the earliest time you
can go to
[Music]
bed God I hope it rains
tomorrow
[Music]
YouTube diss track they'll delay it for
bullying
then God damn
it I have a lot of algae I could
eat and a lot of
ter please rain
tomorrow light
Breeze does that mean Breeze is wind
isn't
it you can go to sleep at five
[Music]
damn farmer
life oh you [__] roonies my rice that
I don't care about okay nice less stuff
to water
now so I want five star of certain items
right or the parsnip
that's an important thing to finish
before the end of the
[Music]
season yeah I granny granny shut
up dumb
Dum these are all sellable aren't they
yeah
grow
[Music]
it's hard to get the three ones I
don't there we go
no I have to stand right in front of it
don't yeah there we
[Music]
go
is it even faster I
[Music]
don't it's a lot of work for these
[__]
plants there's so
[Music]
many
look at my energy dude okay so I will
eat something is this good uh and that's
a lot of energy I like the
[Music]
lake then we'll hit the
mines I should have just eaten these I
have so many what am I
doing
[Music]
damn I really feel my tricep H so
sore I love feeling
sore that means I did
[Music]
good
oh that looks
tasty it's time to mine all day G
Gamers let's make it to 40 oh you can
fish here I won't do that
now I want to upgrade my pickaxe I
really
[Music]
do
corner ooh double
kill we got a cherry
bomb
[Music]
get out of my
face [__] two of them I didn't check the
spirits I just realized I just went for
it I really wanted to
[Music]
go
nice
okay
you should cut the G and break rocks
around the farm area so that your
Swedish aren't destroyed by overgrow
building a fence around your cross will
also stop from being
damaged oh [__] I forgot about the
crows well they H it will be fine they
won't that'll be
fine yeah be
fine dude let me live let me
[Music]
live go boom
boom totally worth
[Music]
it hey fluke
F let's get
it
[Music]
I'm curious if if that damaged the stone
it's eight hits normally one two no he
doesn't okay I get maybe didn't hit
it [__] rise shoots all day
man still haven't found the
exit oops
[Music]
oh my
God got to work for this level
[Music]
huh where is
it
uh
hello my
energy
[Music]
hello wait this Rock's look way
different is that oh
okay did I find the exit already What's
Happening Here
can the exit be under
grass come on cut me some slack
[Applause]
here there we
go I need to eat a
lot
good old
seaweed good all
algae oh I didn't see me get a crab I
can donate that
right
you're right I can make a
steak good
call we going deep tonight
gamers
my [__] sounds are
ridiculous yes didn't grab the s or
whatever all right 25 we're making it
the 30 I have a
feeling
any copper up here no then I don't care
26 let's
[Music]
go hey copper
topes
[Music]
nice I'm not sure if it's true but I
think you get more minerals by upgrading
your tools as well right oh
[Music]
gosh oh that was
quick
quick scan oo
amethyst leave me
alone
okay care more about
levels oh change change
change energy low again
nice
lucky quick
scan oh mine cart fluk
SW
topz make a Rin look at the bugs they
look [__] traumatized I'm not going to
kill you I'm going to murder
you
wait where was it
here I think I still need to eat
something num
n okay
cool that's a lot of
energy [__] mushroom gang
man
geod
o
Hello whoa oh my gosh am I
full uh guess I can eat
algae I definitely need that
hardwood what
else
uh
what
zap zap the
zap oh my gosh I need
those the fiber biscuit is really good I
want to save that for
more I guess
that yeah I don't I don't know if that
was the right call but I did it seed as
I need to get the [__] out of
here what the
hell 30
I'm out
success I kept the fiber after all [__]
why did I do that all right
whatever wait you can block I didn't
realize what's that
sound do you guys hear
that oh it's my blocking
okay or was
it
confused Swedish
noises
uhoh
drama drama drama drama
is there anything I can
donate probably let's
check perer fish ghost fish you get in
the mines uh crab what about my
crab
there we go you belong crab you're
special he PS have a great week first
time seeing the game honestly looks
great I'm going to buy later awesome
yeah have fun check it out
Marco
um we still need these
[__] do I not I thought I donated the
carrot am I
crazy
get the
barries was that the barries will made
here we go there's the
carry and the mushroom
cool and then sap and mor moral
ew uh get the Bears can I just I'll just
get it tomorrow I saw a ton of bushes
before
it's getting
late slay four of the crab things yeah I
can do
that the community center gets repaired
the more Quest and stuff we donate items
we don't I
mean it's cool to see it
change as it
goes all right uh uh uh should I sell
these maybe I'll keep the amethyst for
the
girl
[Music]
[__] got a lot of
copper I should burn it before I go to
bed we can sell the
mushrooms uh-oh we got
trouble a
s
yo don't need that now but it's good
I'll take
it watch out for weeds if they're Clos
they destroy your farm overnight
what are there weeds
nearby oh my gosh yeah they're getting
closer
shush all right parsnip nice gold star
please gold star yes we got
[Music]
one we need three more
[__] anything else
[Music]
finished
oh my
gosh
[Music]
cam just have to look at the square I
didn't
[Music]
realize
dang
[Music]
it
maybe get rid of
these
you guys are
lagging okay well here's the
bush oh the
salmonberry who have I not spoken
[Music]
to
is it you I can't talk to her what a
[Music]
[__] is it you have I not spoken to you
oh my God he was the last
one
yes no wait was it not what no
reward give someone a gift but I've done
that all
right
here here
here you get salmonberry salmonella
Berry there you go you're allergic what
a great
[Music]
gift guess we should build a coupe
then I do want the better
pickaxe this is quite the
Dilemma
[Music]
my romantic interesting Shane and Shane
only
really I also have a side thing with the
the amythyst girl Al Alber Al I don't
remember her
[Applause]
name how much does Ayo cost to build
then
[Applause]
they're cheap oh okay I assume I need
some materials for it
though well I should definitely get a
silo
[Applause]
then ah come
on Stone clay and copper clay really I
don't know how much clay I have I think
I have one at
least
thunderstones 100 100 gold H Stones 10
clay five
coppers copper bars or copper
orse how do I get clay then you just dig
the Earth
right okay
[Music]
h
[Applause]
what what is
that I don't know if I can do that fix
I'm
sorry
you can dig in the beach
too just H around
[Applause]
[Music]
okay oh my gosh the easy ones are
sometimes
harder
oh fishing
[Music]
[Applause]
spot a you did me
dirty
seriously
you know it's the same [__] fish cuz
of the same
[Applause]
pattern yeah sardines moved like
that another
sardine right off the bat I know
it well I was
wrong yo Driftwood super
rare
sardine maybe
not what do we get a fish inside the
fish the
[__] I think it's time to eat the
cookies what the [__] was that
damn this spot is
delivering
sardines
no you're going to be
[Music]
rich
[Applause]
sardine damn that was fast god damn this
is
awesome
sardine ah you
snake I think my inventory is full no wa
it
isn't cuz I'm catching the same [__]
[__] fish all over
again damn how long is this staying
usually they disappear so
quick o close call
[Music]
nice
sardine ah come on
sardini I'm breaking my balls
man God
[Applause]
damn
shame the sardines aren't worth [__] but
we're catching a
lot I'm staying for as long as the
bubbles
are [__] sto
[Applause]
here
[__] it never
stops got to be rich definitely getting
the
pickaxe
oops oops oh God
no we have bug meat it's okay it's only
400 p.m. dude I catch so
much can't stop won't stop eating the
bug
meat no that's not what I want to do
stop it
please God damn
[Applause]
it oh you thought I wasn't going for the
treasure didn't
you don't have space for
Treasures ah [__] Ro macaroni and my
[__] [__] did I
just why is he not going away I never
seen them last this
[Music]
long
well we're definitely liming up our
fishing
tonight is time not moving what the [__]
is still
[Applause]
for no
stop God
damn how is it still
there time stops when you reel the fish
that's why it's going so slowly holy
[__] gold
mine that can be here forever
[Music]
dude all right this looks like a
different fish at least no no it
isn't yeah it is all right I eat the
fish to to get the
fish wait don't I have
algae
seaweed don't go away don't go
away
[Applause]
ah I'm going to break this fishing world
record
dude
[Applause]
[Music]
6: p.m. come on what is happening
[Applause]
that was
[__] what is
happening why
is do I just I'm going to be stuck here
forever I'm stuck in a Time
Loop willly is is there getting [__] all
I'm showing that [__] how a real
fisherman does
it hey Willie you catching
any I'm going to [__] roll Willie
I'm going to retire early
Willie my kids are going to college
Willie you even have kids
Willie this is
ridiculous
[Music]
[__] I would have I
caught willly is
seething [__]
beta this why I'm
Chad oh my God make it
I'm kind of love it and hate
it
will is like can you stop making times
let stop oh
chest oops oops
okay
[__] what in the the world I I can just
apply it right away
nice Will's crying
dude
oops please no more I'm too
rich please what do I get rid of
honestly what do I get rid
of the coal I need the
coal if I don't if I get rid of the food
I can't eat and I need
the yeah but I need the seawing
for
can I just eat it
now the clam but I need the clam to
donate but I guess I'll find more I'll
find more I'll find more no problem
we're in a roll we we a stopping
[Applause]
here
are you [__] kidding
me I cannot have much uh bait
[Applause]
left Willie hasn't caught a single one
[__] how's it going over there Willie
hey Willie arey you catching any
fishy I'm fishing till I die
dude oh not a
treasure I'm too rich stop giving me
Treasures
please oh thank God
okay go home Willie you're not getting
any
Trash oh my
God this is insane is the game glitched
out I don't get it what's
happening okay okay
okay what I never even seen that [__]
what do I get rid of the Earth
crystal the Earth
crystal I get rid of an Earth
crystal uh
uh H [__] it it's too late I got to make
a choice I already donated one Earth
crystal
Willie call the record books they need
to see
these call the cops I don't
know oh I got a [__] halet I am so
rich I am too rich what is a h now what
do I get rid night
IR H where do I put the
[Applause]
Albert I got too much
face what do I get rid of
oh it breaks my
heart I'm out here tossing away iron
Willie this is
crazy I'm getting different fish now oh
my God not [__] treas
[Music]
again Willie Willie get your out of me
Willie okay oh oh what the [__] Z all
right copper is gone the copper is
[Applause]
gone maybe I should just
leave oh I got a [__] hell of
ITT
no stop
[Applause]
trash oh [__] I'm I'm oh [__] I need to
stop fishing I forgot about my
energy I'm never leaving eat the and
show
me so tasty what's the shittiest fish I
have
[Applause]
I eat the fish to get the fish I eat the
fish to get the
fish world star is anyone filming this
on their
iPhone five star five star Five Star
Gold star hell
yeah oh [__] a [__] what oh
it's a purple [__] it's a purple one
what do I
do oh [__] I'm I'm getting really
low what do I
want
what
copper
[Music]
Cole it disappeared it
disappeared
oh that was it what a [__] fishing
spree oh not not a [__] treas are you
serious I don't want to open
it
[__] sake oh my God oh my
God what do I
do
help
I have five sardines I'm not andovi the
anovi is
gone or the
Halbert spoon what about what's wrong
with the spoon you guys don't like
spoons [__] it spoon's gone I'm out [__]
you Willie suck my suck my oh my God
that was crazy m
are you serious I just found
this do I not have it on me I don't have
my hoe on me thank God because that was
worms
there that was
insane how many fish did we catch I
didn't want to count
that 3
6 8 10 20
22 oh my god dude uh 31 3
uh uh 3
32 wait did I count this
wrong around 50 is that
true
oh my
god well I better level up
fishing I can make a mayonnaise machine
sprinklers
yes M that's it 3,000 for all that
[__] for all that
keeps
going I'm
rich good morning Gamers I'm
rich is that a is that done
C
[Music]
now all the towns folk are going to suck
up to me cuz they have so much
money that was the longest day I've ever
had in the game just cuz I didn't near
[__] that was crazy
[Music]
[__]
absolute
Bonkers I know Sven I was away all day
I'm
sorry I had to do
[Music]
it I need to donate the cauliflower
don't I yeah
[Music]
hold up hold up I don't have any copper
now do
I yeah I do have
copper and I had Cal so I did the right
choice s gets water
Tonight Tonight
gamers
hey give me give me give me give me give
me give
me you make give me give me can't you
see wait have I done everything there oh
construction I need I think I have do I
have 10 I got a lot
before okay it's up here that I need
to work
on cauliflower Bing I just need parsnip
and bean I think I'm growing paret and
bean as well for that
matter
I'm Romancing
Shane whether he likes it or
not yeah I'm building a coupe God damn
it hey M man you want some
berries oh he likes berries what's up
Shane Shane likes Pizza no he likes
berries I know my [__] I don't know how
to treat her
right uh
boom yeah you better hurry up CL the
S get out of my face get out of my
face why is she talking about children
with me get them away from
[Music]
me
that it's not where I clicked there we
go I thought it might be a good time to
collect some wood since I don't have my
pickaxe for a couple
days these are really
good you just get them from
bushes
there's a hidden Bush behind that tree I
see
you I see you girl give me
that salmonberry such a weird
[Music]
name
yes so I need to donate 100 200 wood
[__] that's a
lot damn these salmon bears are really
good
though
[Music]
salmon is a fish period I agree
100% I love the design of the wizard
tower feel like I've seen it
somewhere
[Music]
is it worth chopping these you just get
one yeah maybe I should clear out my
area instead you're right I don't know
why I'm clearing up this [__]
[Music]
place we do need to chop a lot of
wood we got the salmon berries on our
side
[Music]
yeah they're more energy the low low
ones I don't get it why would you just
chop
this they're more energy efficient
what now I'm
confused my whole life lie my whole life
[Music]
lie so I chop one I get one I chop 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9
[Music]
10 and I
get oh my
God 12 so no it's not more energy
efficient what the [__] are you
smoking
[Music]
shush just eat the
Barry trees I don't know I think some
naturally spawn if I don't know if I'm
right or wrong but you you definitely
have to plant them for them to grow as
well at least
[Music]
I really should be planting them but I'm
not because
reasons
unknown well I did plant someone in my
base you have to grow trees
yeah
well we can plant some 23
apparently okay
um
[__] can sell these
I have 300 wood plus okay I have enough
wood I only have one hard wood I thought
for some reason that I had 10 what the
[__] and how how much clay do I have two
give me my hoe back where's my
hoe
call it an early
day o
cool we can get the maple
Maple all up in my a hole okay um hey we
got a new fishing rod as
well the best one cool are these done
nope these are
done
why do I buy so
many four cross good job
man
nice nice I'll take you they're
mine cuz I'm M all
day I'm M all night I'm
yeah
yeah see I would cut down these trees
and Marc would be like don't do that
that's illegal and then she calls the
cops on
me and I have to explain to them what
happened and it's it just it's not it's
not
great Sebastian wants green
bean I think I'll have that soon I
didn't read the rest maybe they s
something
else Mar is correct yeah she usually is
unfortunately for
[Music]
me give me
something [__] you
Gunter
so should I just look for clay doing
this is this
dumb I need 10
clay
gosh is there no better
way
oh right I can't
forgot I don't have my pickaxe I can't
dig in the
mines
this is so
dumb get him at the
beach I usually get lots at the all
right we're going to the
beach that's
it
how [__] long have I been Life 5
hours
what when did this
happen
oh
[Music]
one that's supposed to be a penis it
doesn't even look like a
penis oh o my man
is this the bridge that I can
fix sure okay happen to have it
anyway can I donate the
coral what the [__] I never even gone
here hey who the hell are
you
what I need uh two
more yeah I I'll sell the coral don't
worry
um I need the clay
though
the random oh it worked okay one more
come on let's get
it getting
tired one more one more come
on [__] all right Mission failed we'll
get him next
time tree does not
vibrate oh the three ones
oysters oh I can get it from geod as
well and we'll will definitely get I
think we get the pickaxe tomorrow oh n
there
this is
spoopy go in
Vincent Gunter has the key
oh
oh that's a sewer
area go home children
okay got the point I got the
gist me and Shane are hitting it off
really well as you can
tell hey scream if you've seen some
worms by all
means
I meant to pick up one and there's like
a 500 here what's
happening
worms worms worms worms worms worms
worms worms worms
all my worms I need the
worms yeah crispy berries must be really
old okay let's cut down then I need wood
again now that I paid 300 for that
[__] actually
150 I need
uh another 300 so another 150
e
I wonder why no time goes when you're
fishing but chopping wood does
right
strange people are very strange these
days
should I have gone for the catfish no I
don't need money now money problem is
solv
Rich oh my inventory is
full
okay I need another
oh my God what are you
doing okay that should be
enough one more for good
luck
time to hit the hay
Gamers um okay
bye bye and the oyer we keep we sell the
rest what about the muscle muscle too
okay
sup
[Music]
svan damn we're making STS
dude I know I have two clay in my chest
that I'm counting for that I just need
one
more my pickaxe is ready what about my
strawberries not yet okay sh
[Music]
shame are these ready yes oh a lot is
ready
damn
sweet
[Music]
you need a fresh cauliflower
for who's jod I have
[Music]
cauliflower
oops I need a 100 Stone as well I don't
have enough
Stone 40 more Stones we need to hit the
m at some
point let's make some
[Music]
donations yeah let's go to blacksmith
first I'll stop by
[Music]
here oh my God tomorrow's Shane's
birthday I got a buy
pizza you're
[Music]
right parsnip and bean I'm growing beans
but no parsnip so I got to do that and I
need that as well so I should buy a
bunch of part Snips
next sorry what am I looking for I'm
looking for the building bundle where is
that is that down
here let's just get it
done
Shane my man how are you don't don't I
have work to do you're right Shane I do
you're so funny
[__] uh opens at 12
okay remind me on the way back that I
have to buy a pizza and beer for Shane
cuz we're so close dude we're so [__]
tight
dude we're like a rock that's glued to
another rock that's how tight we
are hey give me my [__] pickaxe thank
you thanks for nothing Clint you're a
real stinker all right hey gos give me
clay nope
clay nope clay
what the [__] is that
clay Clint you [__] you you [__]
[__] [__] [__] [__]
[Music]
[__]
orange any
rewards oh [__] star fruit seed plant
these in summer
okay
[Music]
we're hitting the mines I need
Stone someone needed a cauliflower but I
don't know who she
is Jodie I don't know who that is
[Music]
could be
anyone dang
it dang
[Music]
it [__] okay I forgot I need to go to
the shop as
[Music]
well for some
nips shut
up you're a
child what's
happening what's
[Music]
happening why is he acting like I never
entered
before oh it's JoJo Cola
man what a boss
move come around and get it folks coupon
for 50 50% off that's a
steal
50% well any takers yes yes
absolutely
uh
yeah okay hold up one second
gamers
all
right and must be so difficult for you
to lose your loyal customers like that
but can you blame them JoJo Corporation
is clearly the superior Choice soon the
whole time we realize that and you will
just up the prices you'll [__] us
over it's never worth it support local
businesses
Gamers I don't like I still don't like
you P I think you're a suck up and I see
through your
[__]
anyway see I can't even find your
exit I should really sell some of this
now wait the colorful from someone
else what am I doing with all this crap
my inventory is full I can't go to the
mines
[__] Pizza uh I can't buy the pizza
until 2:
p.m. we'll go and plant the seeds get
the pizza and then we [__]
Shane Jody's bottom
left how does she look like Brook tell
me
[Music]
now sh
garbage
hey maybe we maybe we get some clay
now or maybe not you know who's who
really
[Music]
cares
damn
[Music]
it
how
[Music]
what's that two clay that I
had did I grab it did I calculate wrong
I need three
more
[__] does these ever finish
[Music]
growing oh my God it is fin
fin oh it's two hey Sven let me just
check if I can find the
girl
[Music]
uh was it Jodie yeah Jodie she live
here are you
[Music]
Jodie a get get out of my
face there's some worms you're right
thank you thank you thank
you clay
[Music]
what dang
it all right I'll make a lap around into
town then
I'm definitely not buying a house I mean
a hat or a
house oh it doesn't lap around for
[__] sake what about here here we
go
oh I
see I see I see I see I
see uh should I get two gifts for is
maybe no um can I walk
here are you serious
okay uh two pizza two pizzas or one
pizza two pizza or one pizza how many
pizza for my main Beach
[Music]
H Jody oh
Jodie are you
Jody are you
[Music]
Jodie
two pizzas that's
crazy well he's going to be hella happy
is that
jod y
y oh my God I'm not talking to [__] you
Haley suck my
ass
okay I don't need judgment from someone
that talks about plastic shoes okay here
we go pizza pizza pizza pizza pizza I
need pizza
my inventory is full are you serious uh
why does this keep happening to me every
goddamn time I don't need this can I
place this okay
pizza two pizzas for my main man all
right as how does jod look like are you
Jodie now you're Pam are you
Jodie now you're
Leah are you Jodie you're Pierre are you
Jodie no you're Robin
hey man how you doing excited for your
birthday
tomorrow oh get out of my
way oh my God he's blocking he's they're
blocking
me they're blocking me I am
trapped here uh do you like
stones [__]
[Music]
sake where's
Jodie
are you jod y Jody aren't
you I hate you penny so much you're
garbage you're trash you belong in the
trash you belong here I can't even click
on
it I'm just going to wait
here
wait she's in the
house
where oh my God it goes oh y Yodi I got
K
yeah
300 [__] you
jod [__] you in your big
house rich
[__] oh I'm so excited for Shane's
birthday tomorrow oh my God it's going
to be the best tomorrow is Shane's
birthday holy [__] dude Shane's birthday
is going to be the [__]
best we got pizza we got a
thing oh it's going to be
sick oh I forgot I need
to I need to plant a bunch of stuff
don't I or did I do that already I
already did that okay
uh I I keep holding on to this amethyst
for some
reason get away get away get away get
away uh I don't know what to do with you
we'll deal with you later the pizza is
important okay I'm actually I have to uh
I've been playing way too long five and
a half hours I think it's time to end
it I'm going to end it there guys till
next time Shane's birthday we're going
to the game crashed anyway are you
serious what the game
crashed oh it's telling me it's actually
telling me to stop are you serious no it
did not say my last day of pizza
buying oh and it's it's doing all I
didn't even click
any
[__] anyway thanks for watching
guys thank you everyone for all the
support I really appreciate it and
especially in times like these you're
the best thank you seriously all right
that's it have a great one have a great
Sunday enjoy the rest of
it
bye-bye bye-bye
byebye